Traductor: Marta Serrano Sánchez
Revisor: Larisa Esteche
¿Qué hay del otro lado del silencio?
Esta pregunta me acompaña
hace mucho tiempo.
Y es un viaje hermoso por el que me lleva.
Es algo que cada vez me tira respuestas
tan interesantes como curiosas.
Pero sé que es algo que todos,
aún sin saberlo,
ya lo sabemos.
En el proceso de bajar las ideas
para esta charla
nos invitan a todos los oradores
a un conversatorio sobre
"vida consciente".
Vamos todos felices, espectacular el tema,
las charlas, la gente,
y uno de los oradores de ese día,
que hoy es maestro de ceremonia,
el gordito,
(Risas)
empieza a hablar sobre un tema
que me deja seco.
El lenguaje que utilizaba,
cómo lo articulaba,
la claridad de sus ideas.
Darme cuenta de que esta persona,
que no iba a ser oradora,
tenía las ideas tan claras,
me hizo hacer una cosa.
Entrar en "modo pánico".
Como decía nuestra compañera,
"zona mágica", "zona pánico",
y yo estaba del lado de afuera de ahí,
básicamente.
El primer paso
cuando entro en "modo pánico"
es que me desconecto
y corto toda conexión con la realidad
porque justamente de ahí
viene esta sobrecarga sensorial.
Segundo paso, entra la hermana Duda
con una patada voladora,
como la que hablaba Luis
sobre su profesor,
a barrer cualquier rastro de confianza
que pudiera haber.
Esta última crisis fue muy importante
porque me iluminó de una manera distinta.
Me enseñó que el último paso
de mi "modo pánico"
es que me viene un sueño terrible.
No es tipo un "uf" y ya.
No. Me apago.
No importa a quién tenga enfrente.
Me ha tocado dejar personas así
que no entienden qué pasa.
Una vez una chica terminó conmigo
y yo me dormí,
la otra no entendía qué pasaba.
La confusión fue para ella.
(Risas)
Pero bueno.
Esta situación me mostró
que mi cuerpo y mi mente han desarrollado
esta herramienta muy útil
que la ponen en práctica
cuando mi "modo pánico"
empieza a coquetear con su amante de años.
El estúpido y sensual "auto-sabotaje".
Así nomás.
Mi cuerpo y mi mente decidieron
que esta conducta autodestructiva
no va más
y encontraron la forma clara y contundente
de decírmelo.
"Así no".
Es muy loco ver cómo esta comunicación
no es solo en un sentido.
No es solo que mi cuerpo me habla a mí
sino que yo también puedo hablar con él.
Es un diálogo fisiológico constante
lo que tenemos en la vida.
Y todos, todos,
por más santitos que seamos,
tenemos esa voz, en segundo plano,
que nos va comentando en tiempo real
toda nuestra vida.
Creemos que eso, ese fenómeno,
es la intuición.
Y es una suerte de sensibilidad
que poseemos todos.
¿Okey?
Ahora, esta intuición es música.
¿Por qué?
La música, en teoría,
se divide en tres elementos.
Ritmo, melodía y armonía.
El ritmo es una serie de sonidos
que suceden cada cierta frecuencia
que pueden variar en intensidad,
de más suave a más fuerte,
o en duración, de más cortos a más largos.
La melodía se compone de todas las notas.
Desde las más graves hasta las más agudas.
Todas.
Y la armonía es la proporción adecuada
que hay entre todos los elementos
de un conjunto.
Ahora, ¿por qué esta intuición es música?
Porque el cuerpo, nosotros,
en la dualidad física que representamos,
física del cuerpo y abstracta en la mente
y consciencia de todo lo que somos,
se comporta de la misma manera.
Y está reflejado en este mismo fenómeno.
El ritmo, en el plano físico
es nuestra frecuencia cardíaca.
Nos va marcando el pulso en la vida.
En el plano abstracto,
es nuestra respiración.
La melodía, en el plano físico
es nuestra voz.
Vibración física.
En el plano abstracto,
son nuestras emociones.
Energía en movimiento.
La armonía, en el plano físico
es nuestra postura.
Cómo nos alineamos con nosotros mismos.
En el plano abstracto,
es nuestra inteligencia emocional.
Imaginémonos una línea imaginaria, ¿ya?
Por eso nos la imaginamos,
porque es imaginaria.
Donde van todas nuestras emociones.
Desde las más graves,
la tristeza, la angustia, la depresión,
hasta las más agudas,
la euforia, la felicidad, la alegría.
Dependiendo en qué emoción
y en qué estado emocional estemos
van a subir
ciertas frecuencias de esa emoción.
Si estamos tristes o deprimidos,
vamos a tener un sesgo
de este lado de la línea imaginaria
que nos estamos imaginando
que va a generar una especie de curva.
Esta curva.
Debajo de la curva estamos nosotros,
del otro lado está el mundo.
Esta curva en particular,
tan triste y depresiva,
nos está sesgando
nuestra percepción del mundo.
No estamos mal.
Lo entendemos así
porque así nos sentimos en ese momento.
Nada más.
Ahora, todo muy lindo con todo esto.
Sí, Salvador, qué poético,
la música, la intuición, blah blah.
Pero, ¿cómo se conecta todo?
Es muy fácil.
Todos ustedes, todos nosotros,
los de arriba, equipo hermoso,
público, divino,
mi persona, todos los de acá,
todos escuchamos música y hemos visto
gente escuchar música.
Y siempre que hay algo de música
alguien reacciona,
sea el típico que mueve el cuellito,
o el baterista amateur que siempre está
ahí marcando todo en su falda, en la mesa,
el que vuelve loca a la familia,
"callate nene", ese.
La música funciona así.
Hay algo dentro de ella que no vemos,
que se comunica con algo dentro nuestro,
que decodifica algo
que nos hace reaccionar y suceder
en función de.
De esta misma manera trabaja la intuición,
solo que quizá nunca
le dimos la oportunidad.
¿Por qué?
Porque estamos acostumbrados a que
la comunicación siempre ha sido la misma.
Afuera. Sentidos y percepción. Interior.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa cuando el mensaje
o el emisor está adentro?
Y nosotros mismos somos el receptor.
Ahí "pantalla azul" y no entendemos.
Pero a medida
que nos vamos entregando a esto,
vamos entendiendo que este diálogo
fisiológico del que hablamos
lo vivimos todos los días.
Y nosotros elegimos qué tan parte de ello
vamos a ser.
El mensaje central de la música
como lenguaje de la intuición
es aprender
a escuchar nuestra respiración.
Reconocer la melodía de nuestras emociones
y alinear nuestras posturas y cuerpos
para que desde el silencio de esa armonía
surja la verdadera música,
reconociendo así nuestra propia canción.
Ahora, asterisco número dos.
Todo muy lindo, Salvador,
con tu mensaje, pero
¿cómo hago yo, si ya me estoy escuchando,
para saber cuándo logré
ese estado de armonía?
El tema es el siguiente.
Si esta voz de la intuición que tenemos
nos invita a prender fuego todo
y a reventarnos contra el mundo,
podríamos seguir escuchando,
o "selección natural", a veces pasa.
Ahora, si esta voz nos invita a conciliar
y a resolver algo,
a desatar lo que queríamos cortar,
eso nos va a llevar a un estado
donde vamos a sentirnos muy agradecidos
por haber encontrado
esta válvula de escape sana.
Y es desde este agradecimiento
donde todo empieza a cambiar.
Porque desde el agradecimiento,
el mundo empieza a sentir
como que fluye de una manera distinta,
de una mejor manera.
Entonces...
(respira)
Es así, muy sencillo.
Qué hay del otro lado del silencio,
les pregunto.
Nosotros.
Música.
Nuestra música.
Y es nuestra naturaleza,
como música que somos,
escucharnos y fluir a nuestro son.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)